il ya déjà des vaccins qui sont
obligatoires quand on intègre les
filières de la santé notamment
l'hépatite b et c
donc on vit une crise quand même qu'un
majeur on est confiné des cons finir
confiné on a vu l'hôpital dans tous ses
états ces derniers temps ça ne paraît
pas illogique de rendre obligatoire
cette vaccination donc soigner on a fait
un choix c'est d'aider les autres et on
sait que le coc vide a été surtout
pendant les premières vagues
une des principales causes d'infections
nosocomiales c'est le personnel soignant
le transmettait à des patients affaiblis
venus se faire opérer ou quoi que ce
soit chacun prend ses responsabilités et
on peut pas questionné sur qui est
vaccinée ou pas puisque c'est personnel
c'est médical donc on n'a pas le savoir
maintenant le message qui est passé bien
entendu c'est la protection de tous et
de pas avant une hécatombe également sur
sur notre rh et sur le nombre de
personnel dans les services pour moi et
pour le syndicat sud santé sociaux
cette décision-là est à prendre du point
de vue personnel de l'agent pour moi
contraindre un agent à se faire vacciner
avec un produit spécifique
c'est un non sens total